19 il s'agit du nombre de restaurants
boucherie ou boulangerie condamné à une
fermeture administrative en 2022 en
Indre-et-Loire pour ne pas avoir
respecté la législation concernant les
règles d'hygiène régulièrement des
contrôles sanitaires sont organisés par
les agents de la direction
départementale de la protection des
populations c'était d'ailleurs le cas ce
jeudi matin sur un marché de jouer les
tours les Turquie
jeudi matin place Nelson Mandela a Joué
les Tours le marché de l'arabière bat
son plein aujourd'hui un contrôle de la
sécurité sanitaire et réalisé par la
direction départementale de la
protection des populations sur l'un des
étals le commerçant souhaite rester
anonyme pendant les vérifications de sa
marchandise ça va être l'aspect général
de l'étal de vente si c'est pas trop
surchargé célébrités les vitrines sont
branchées la propreté et ensuite on va
vérifier les étiquetages les
températures de produits d'exposition
la tenue vestimentaire du personnel
résultat une mise en demeure de
l'établissement pour non-conformité aux
normes d'hygiène des vérifications comme
celle-ci il y en a près de 400 chaque
année en Indre-et-Loire restaurant
boucherie cantine producteur agricole
tous sont concernés tant que cela toucha
l'alimentaire le principal risque c'est
l'intoxication par la présence de
bactéries pathogènes ou de virus dans
l'alimentation qui passe par la
formation du personnel ça passe donc par
ses pratiques au quotidien par l'hygiène
le nettoyage à désinfection et ça passe
aussi par les opérations de maintien au
froid ou les opérations de cuisson de
refroidissement de conservation des
aliments les résultats des contrôles
sont disponibles sur le site et
l'application alim confiance quand la
sécurité sanitaire de l'alimentation
n'est pas assurée les sanctions tombent
donc vous avez quatre niveaux très
satisfaisants satisfaisant à améliorer
et à corriger de manière urgente un
établissement à corriger de manière
urgente sera un établissement fermé l'an
dernier
19 établissements ont été fermés sur
arrêté préfectoral parce qu'il
présentait un risque pour la santé des
consommateurs il est possible de faire
soi-même des signalements de commerce
sur le site internet signal conso par
exemple pour des cas d'intoxication
alimentaire